what's up andrew hey rich how are you
good man what can i do for you
so
first of all i want to say thank you i'm
i'm really excited to talk to you man
because uh your content has been
extremely helpful to me thank you um
honestly what uh part of it exactly like
what what was the change
you one thing that you said am i am i
looking okay is it super blurry dude
listen i'm sitting here on a 480p webcam
in a lake house
or with bad wi-fi it's not worse than
what i'm dealing with trust okay for
sure so
you said something in one of your
broadcasts that it really really stuck
with me basically rate yourself right
the best version of yourself and i did
that i was super honest about it
it was it was not good the results were
not good and i kind of just was like
what did you rate yourself on a scale of
one to ten like a five okay and why
dude i was fat i was like 300 pounds
almost 36 37 body fat was not making
good money
you don't look like you're fat today
though
yeah well i yeah i changed that so okay
like eight percent body fat now um
got pretty shredded
and uh
in like nine months too i just really i
hired a really high level nutritionist
um just changed it around so
guys guys get mad when i say you know to
spend some money on themselves or if you
know you have a question book me for
coaching but it's like
all the highest performing people in the
world have a coach
some sort of counselor somebody to you
know kind of move them along the path
from you know zero to one to two to
three four and so on and so forth
that's awesome man i'm glad so um so
what's your question tonight
so just real quick if i can say one
thing to the community the money that
i've spent on myself my coach is not
cheap it's like 300 a month
um
i have gotten back
way more than that off of how much more
productive i am my test levels my test
levels were 200
what are they like
um
high
okay much higher so i got i got on some
uh some
therapy and it's helped tremendously um
i've been doing combat sports since i
was like 13. so i've been getting hit in
the head forever so they were just
abysmal but the money that you'll spend
on yourself if one suggestion yo it'll
come back you'll make more money you'll
be yeah so my question to you though is
so i really really want and man i'm
so torn on this i want to have a family
i want a wife i want to have kids i want
to stay at home wife i want the whole
thing okay
it
feels hard
oh well yeah i mean it's
the most important decision that you
could possibly make how how old are you
first of all 31
okay and where do you live
uh utah salt lake city and i think you
said you own an mma gym or you're an mma
fighter like okay both yeah okay all
right um your income is pretty strong
uh yeah just hit six figures okay so
like how many kids you wanna have
i i would like like three or four
honestly okay
um and what's the dating like in your
area like what kind of women are you
coming across right now so if i've never
i've never been in this good of shape
since i've been dating um it's insane
the amount of like my inbox is literally
just filled
it's a game so okay let's just stop on
that for a sec because
there's a lot of dudes out there that
are that get down on themselves how tall
are you six one and what do you weigh
right now 240 okay and what did you
weigh when you were fat 300 pounds okay
so in like nine months you lost that
that amount of weight that's pretty
significant and then the difference in
the attention that you got from before
when you were in dorkville to where you
were today
is quite a bit different right i
literally have hundreds of girls got it
like i'm not joking so guys do the work
anyway sorry to interrupt but carry on
yeah no it's just it's been total it's
it's overwhelming the first week that i
was on the first day that i was on
tinder
like literally it was like 90 likes
immediately and i'm just like i don't
even know what to do with this well
you're a chat so i mean you know things
have changed for you now like you've
gone from you know the fat boy to the
chat sort of thing so
the most important thing that okay so
here's the good news first
fine do it okay the first thing that i
would do is i would take a look at a
video that i put out on my channel or
just search for on
google search for wikipedia
uh shared parenting states
okay okay because i mean the first thing
that you're going to want to do is half
of marriages are going to end in divorce
so you're gonna have to take some
uh
you're gonna have to prepare for that
just in case and if you can live in a
state
where there's default shared custody
that deals with one of the biggest
problems that most men have to contend
with now one of the things that you can
do to minimize the risk of that even
becoming a a problem
is and i put in my book i'm not sure if
you read it oh yeah okay so multiple
times yeah okay so i mean like you
already know this then but one of the
biggest uh determining factors of a
healthy happy long-term relationship and
a woman that compare bond to a guy
properly and not like you know bounce if
things don't work out or
you know some guy named kevin from sales
starts to chat her up you know one day
on on lunch is does she have a low notch
count
right and
the data that i got that i put in my
book and i'll you know cite it again i
know you read it but um i mean your
ideal candidate is going to be a virgin
which is going to be next to impossible
to find maybe you know maybe she's out
there maybe she's not so in utah it's
not that hard actually actually yeah
you're right yeah we have a huge mormon
population
okay so okay so you've got that going
for you but after after i think uh two
to three partners the number was
something like uh 25 to 30 percent and
then they stopped collecting the data at
something like 9 or 10 which ended up
being like 35 chance of getting divorced
um
as as the numbers go up
i'm pretty confident that it gets worse
and worse like a woman with a notch
count of 50 or 100 is going to be a
total train wreck you should never wife
these up right let them be garden
tools let them do what they're going to
do it's not your responsibility to save
them there's going to be some plugged in
beta that's probably going to want to do
that let them fine
those two things would would deal with
most of the problems that you're
possibly going to contend with
okay
make sure you're in a state where shared
custody is default and you get a check
with a low notch count aside from that
you know make sure you're you know she's
a compliment to your life your goals are
aligned you're aligned with parenting
you know sort of thing because that's
where people start to scrap it out
um and give yourself a good two-year
vetting period
two years then that was gonna be my next
question two years yeah minimum two
years okay
because i mean like women can act for
six twelve eighteen months
right there's a lot of guys that i've
talked to that like you know they wiped
up a woman after seven or eight months
and they're like you know got married
and the representative left and i was
left with this one
right
so
with that one one more question for you
is it okay yeah but
um
without incriminating myself too much
here uh spit you know the plate spitting
thing
um
mindset changer right not operating out
of a scarcity mindset
um
has been helpful
uh these girls though that i do want to
date
that that i am dating um that have low
or zero notch count
not super appreciative of that type of
lifestyle what do you think about that
superficial even in the sense of being
intimate with you
just not appreciative of the sense of
like i don't really want you dating
other girls
if we're dating that's
that's pretty much the default that most
women operate in right like women get
jealous because they're afraid that
you're going to take your attention and
resources away from them and give it to
somebody else
right so i mean
if you're dating a woman and you know
you're vetting her basically for mother
stock because that's what your goal is i
mean that's what you're talking about
that's exactly what i'm doing right i
mean like you're gonna have to compare
her to more than just one other woman
there's gonna be a bunch you're gonna
have to you know seek out and you know
see what you're dealing with and she's
going to have to contend with that you
know
like
oh andrew what are you doing friday
night i really want to see you well i'm
busy well what are you doing andrew well
i'm busy you know i'll see you on
saturday or i'll see you on our two
there you know whatever it is that
you're you know doing but it's like if
you got another date you need to tell
her oh well i got a date and we're going
to go here at eight o'clock and this is
what we're going to do and i'm kind of
sizing it up to see how it goes it's
like you're a man on a purpose you're
doing your thing you know it's it's
communicated by
by your availability and your schedule
and what you're doing so just go and do
it right i mean you're not going to stop
doing it because she doesn't want you to
see anybody else you don't know what
she's made of i mean you've only known
her for how long what a couple weeks a
month or two yeah a week yeah two weeks
cool your jets lady
right right yeah so i guess i was just
wondering like these higher quality
women
are they worth making concessions for
because they're higher quality women or
you still don't think so well there's no
unicorns okay there's of course right
there's there's just women
there's some there's some terrible ones
and there's some better ones what what
it what it is that you're trying to do
is you're basically digging through a
lot of dirt to find gold
right so don't
get this like you know mind's eye view
of like you know a a better quality
woman or like one of these higher
quality women you know sort of thing
because there's a lot of guys that
thought that they wifed up a high
quality woman
only to like have you know left that
marriage a few years later because they
discover that she's not really what you
thought they are right
so
don't don't um you know get this notion
or this like um like laser fixation on
oh you know there's a super high quality
unicorn that i'm seeing and i've known
her for a couple weeks and you know
maybe i should stop seeing other girls
because she told me you know to not see
other girls it's like no
you keep doing what you're doing
okay
she's got to earn it man
right
right okay
make sense yeah absolutely dude again
thank you i honestly can't thank you
enough changed my life and i appreciate
it you're welcome i'll see you later man
peace
you